[Música]
en france 24 es momento de hablar de
ciencia y tecnología soy valentina torre
sánchez y es un gusto acompañarlos desde
casa iniciamos con un programa o
software que lanzaron investigadores
suizos para recorrer el espacio con
realidad virtual funciona más o menos
como lo haría google earth en la tierra
y permite ver con precisión la estación
espacial internacional la luna saturno
exoplanetas y galaxias entre otras su
wifi
lo que vemos aquí es la representación
del universo que ha sido obtenida
gracias a una consignación numérica
gigante de hecho gracias a computadores
somos capaces de reproducir la evolución
durante un largo periodo de una porción
del universo lo que nos permite entender
cómo la materia es distribuida alrededor
del universo
es un trabajo liderado por científicos
de la escuela politécnica federal de
lausana y se llama virtual reality
universe project puede ser visto
mediante un equipo individual de
realidad virtual sistemas de inmersión
como cine panorámico con gafas 3d
pantallas de cúpula estilo planetario o
un computador
empezamos por la tierra visitamos
planetas la vía láctea pero también
podemos descubrir la estructura del
universo a gran escala
esta es una forma muy eficiente de
visitar todas las diferentes escalas que
componen nuestro universo y es
completamente único
siguiendo con temas espaciales sería
imposible no mencionar la nueva hazaña
de la compañía de jeff bezos blue origin
que envió su segundo vuelo comercial
fuera de la tierra
y aguardó se encontraba william shatner
el actor que interpretó al legendario
capitán kirk en la serie star trek a los
90 años se convirtió en la persona de
más edad en viajar fuera de nuestro
planeta la aventura se produjo a bordo
del cohete new se parte totalmente
automatizado y reutilizable y duró unos
10 minutos en total en los que la
cápsula superó los 100 kilómetros de
altura
la distancia considerada límite entre la
tierra y el espacio y los tripulantes
pudieron experimentar la gravedad zero
posteriormente tanto shatner como sus
compañeros de misión volvieron a la
tierra sanos y salvos
lo que me diste hoy en la experiencia
más profunda que pude imaginar
pero estoy tan lleno de emoción por lo
que acaba de pasar es extraordinario
extraordinario
del espacio vamos hasta el desierto de
néguev en el sur de israel donde el foro
espacial austriaco y la agencia espacial
israelí recrean las condiciones de marte
allí instalar en su base marciana y un
grupo de astronautas análogos como se
les llama a las personas que reproducen
en la tierra las condiciones de misiones
largas en el espacio vivirán aislados
del mundo durante un mes
tenemos investigadores de 25 países
reunidos para simular la primera misión
humana en martes así que seleccionamos
cuidadosamente a una tripulación de seis
astronautas análogos de varias naciones
que imitan los primeros pasos de nuestra
sociedad en el planeta rojo por un mes
israel será el escenario central de
investigación de misiones humanas
marcianas porque creo firmemente que el
primer humano que caminara en marte ya
nació y robert y forma el grupo llevará
a cabo unos 25 experimentos científicos
entre ellos pruebas con un prototipo de
dron que funciona sin gps así como
estudios con vehículos cartográficos
automáticos que funcionan con energía
solar y eólica la preparación de los
astronautas tomó 2 años e incluyó
pruebas físico y emocionales pues una
parte del estudio consiste en analizar
las consecuencias del aislamiento
controlado
nuestros desafíos son físicos porque al
salir del hábitat a realizar
experimentos
tenemos que usar estos trajes que
requieren mucho trabajo físico requieren
muchísimo esfuerzo es de dover son el
problema más cambiamos de tema y
llegamos a japón porque científicos de
la universidad de osaka están usando
impresoras 3d para crear lo que esperan
sea una alternativa sostenible a la
famosa carne de wagyu este producto
busca replicar de la manera más precisa
posible el marmoleado de esa carne es
decir la grasa que se almacena en las
fibras de los músculos que es lo que la
diferencia de otros tipos de
primero imprimimos el músculo la grasa
los conductos sanguíneos en forma de
fibra al usar la anatomía microscópica
de la carne como modelo y observar para
reconstruir la fibra pensamos que
podríamos crear una estructura de karma
los investigadores extrajeron células
bobinas de vacas japonesas negras de las
que proviene esta carne luego usaron una
bio impresora 3d para fabricar cada
pieza por aparte y posteriormente
unirlas el equipo reconoce que por el
momento el sabor no tiene posibilidad de
éxito y falta tiempo para lograr
imitarlo además explican que actualmente
toma cuatro semanas generar un
centímetro cúbico de agua sin embargo
resaltan que en cinco años podría
producirse masiva y exitosamente
finalizamos con una nueva hazaña de la
inteligencia artificial en el pasado
ordenadores fueron capaces de completar
sinfonías de gustav más la ofensivas
pues ahora el turno fue para beethoven
que al morir dejó inconcluso a su décima
sinfonía les decía néstor hasta
configurar ya no es que el computador
haya dado una sola versión copió varias
y los humanos hicimos las elecciones
tengan en mente su vida grabar y así es
como ve todo el mismo trabajaba se
llevaba su libreta de apuntes y hacía
cambios hasta que tenían una versión que
pensaba que era perfecta eso significa
que la cuestión no puede solucionarse
sin equivocaciones creo que suena como
todo esto
y hay momentos en los que su espíritu y
realmente apareció y sacar esto of saint
así llegamos al final de este espacio a
ustedes gracias por acompañarme y
recuerden que pueden repetir esta y
otras emisiones en nuestra web france24
puntocom
[Música]